on Monday morning there were 12 inches
of snow on the ground the weather warmed
up and by Tuesday morning two inches had
melted all right so we'll have ten left
two more inches melted by Wednesday
morning this pattern continued
throughout the week until no more snow
was left so they're essentially saying
that we had 12 inches of snow on the
ground on Monday and that every day
after that two inches melted so after
after Tuesday you would have 10 inches
and after Wednesday you'd have eight
inches and that pattern continued and
what they say is create an equation and
a graph to show the relationship between
the day and the amount of snow on the
ground so let's define a variable that
tells us how far away we are from Monday
so let's let's let let's let X equal two
days after Monday days after Monday days
after Monday and then let Y let Y be
equal two inches of snow on the ground
inches of snow snow on the ground
so one way to think about it is okay Y
when we have when X is zero when we're
on Monday when we're zero days after
Monday we're going to have 12 inches of
snow on the ground and then every day
after that we're going to lose two
inches so if we're on Tuesday we're
going to have two inches times one
because Tuesday is one day so if X is
one that means we're on Tuesday if X is
two that means we've lost what that
means we're two times two we've lost
four inches which is what the case is on
Wednesday so this is our equation for
the relationship between the day and the
amount of snow on the ground X is the
day how many days after Wednesday I'm
sorry after Monday and then why is the
inches of snow left on the ground we
start with twelve and then every day we
lose exactly two inches now let's graph
this let's graph it so if this I'll make
my vertical axis the y-axis that's
inches on the ground Y is equal to in
is left on the ground and then the
horizontal axis that is our x-axis let
me scroll down a little bit this is this
is days after days after Monday days
after Monday and so we have zero days
after Monday we have one two three four
five and six and then on Monday which is
exactly zero days after Monday that is
Monday we have 12 inches on the ground
so I'll do it up here so we have 12 we
have 12 inches on the ground right there
and actually I could do a table if you
like let me draw this so if we do X's
and X & Y if you do X & Y this is the
days after Monday so we want 0 1 2 3 4 5
6 and then on the first day we have 12
inches on Monday zero days after Monday
then we lose two inches each day on day
one we have 10 day 2 8 6 4 to 0 so let's
plot these points we ready plotted 0 12
in that blue color now let's plot 110
110 is right about there it'll be right
over there then we can plot 2 8 so off
to days after Monday we have 8 inches
left on the ground so this is on
Wednesday so that's 8 inches and then on
on for days or no around 3 days after
Monday we have 6 inches on the ground so
three days we have 6 inches on the
ground and you can see that a line is
forming here and then if we go to four
days after Monday we have four inches on
the ground four days after Monday we
have four inches on the ground so that
is four and then five days after Monday
we have two inches on the ground so five
days after Monday we have two inches on
the ground
and then finally on the sixth day six
days after Monday so what do we add
Sunday now we are going to have no
inches on the ground so that's that
right there and you can see that there's
this line that formed because this is a
linear relationship it looks a little
curvy because I didn't draw it perfectly
but that is a line so we've done
everything we've created the equation we
start with twelve inches every day after
that we lose two inches and we show it a
graph that depicts the relationship